el más reciente acontecimiento en la
impactante historia del envenenamiento
de alexéi navalni el líder opositora
asegura que consiguió engañar a un
agente del servicio de seguridad federal
de rusia para que revelara detalles del
ataque en su contra realizado con el
agente no que los tenemos contra
la pared hay más que suficiente
evidencia ahora pero no la presentaré
ante una corte sólo lo puedo entregar a
los ciudadanos de rusia haciéndose pasar
como un funcionario de seguridad naval
ni dice que contactó a un especialista
en armas químicas llamado constantin
julia sep la llamada se hizo como una
trampa para que pareciera hecha desde un
teléfono fijo de las fuerzas de
seguridad rusas
el agente afirma que fue enviado para
tomar la ropa de navalny y retirar
cualquier rastro de no que tras el
ataque también dice que el novillo que
se puso en la ropa interior de naval ni
clavamos su ropa con blanqueador nos
aseguramos que no quedaran rastros o
nada similar la voz más crítica contra
el presidente vladimir putin colapsó a
bordo de un avión ruso en agosto y se
recupera en berlín después de semanas
bajo cuidados intensivos y la gente
engañado declara que la rápida respuesta
del piloto y el equipo médico en el
aeroplano prueba
salvaron la vida de naval ni si el vuelo
hubiera sido un poco más largo y no
hubieran aterrizado tan temprano las
cosas habrían terminado de manera
distinta desde el servicio de seguridad
federal de rusia expresaron que el vídeo
publicado en el canal de youtube de
naval ni es falso y que la llamada fue
una provocación que tenía como objetivo
desprestigiar la agencia el kremlin
sigue negando cualquier vínculo entre el
estado ruso y el envenenamiento de naval
ni